if they met all our young boys Johnny
saris then how come we still have a
Greek nation how come we Greeks are
still there we still speak Greek and we
are still Greek worship one God
straightforward simple basically
nationality stays the same
I will die Greek and sha Allah so that's
also for my parents that they know that
I will die greatly test if people want
to know how do I know you just think
okay okay lets us point our iqtalk state
delay to islam dr steph get that's great
yes and you're from the background he
accepted islam 20 years ago you accept
this rose right it's correct and guess
what he's from a Greek background and
some people out there is like oh he
became a Turk what'd he have to say to
that you know in the Balkans like this
of people identify their religion they
put you together with a nationality so
as soon as you become Muslim you become
a Turk but that's a very important point
with you to realize that when you become
a Muslim you become a Muslim you don't
change nationality but you change
religion or actually way of life let's
call it that word because Islam is
actually a Dean it's a way of life guys
it's not just a religion you know
there's much more to it and everybody
who's practicing Islam Allah says what
I'm what I was saying what I want to say
with that basically nationality stays
the same
I will die Greek and sha Allah so that's
also for my parents that they know that
I will die Greek so I didn't change that
reality and I still have the same skin
color I haven't changed that so
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
what changes by way of life which has
become better hamdulillah and I've
become a more fulfilled person Hum Dil I
got married I have seven children now
hamdulillah so I'm quite happy with my
way of life and this chosen way of life
since 1992 which is how is it 26 36 yeah
wow this is amazing because we have
what's important now is we have so many
people who are coming to the realization
that there's a purpose in life
I want to live it you had to go through
so many challenges because now you're
not just going to accept Islam for the
fun of it so you really put it to the
test
safe to say I mean three years you're
investigating three - yeah it took me
three years to come to the point to say
Shahada three years I mean you have to
understand again as we said from the
region where I come from we come from
Mexico from the Balkan Peninsula people
identify themselves with you know
religion and nationality is one thing is
the same thing for them so we've done a
thing changing religion means also
changing nationality according to them
but that did not happen that's not my
idea of course hamdulillah we became
Muslim my family is Muslim
my wife by the way is also a revert she
is from South America so also for her it
was like accepting for them down there
it's more being an Indian yeah so you're
not you're not you don't become a
Pakistani you don't become you don't
become because you're Muslim you kind of
Arab you know just the same way if you
become a Muslim you don't become a Turk
no you just become someone who has
submitted to look at this this is this
is turn on to like light walk turn on
the brain Muslim is one who submits to
the will of the creator not the creation
that's what a Muslim is that's not you
chose to do that after deep
contemplation research based on proof
and evidence and you're here on the D
show today and actually now you actually
you're a historian so you really talk to
us about that because you have to you
know there's a lot of these myths that
are perpetuated you got some truth in
there and you got a mixed in with
half-truths and lies and all this bunch
of hog college and the big buffet right
and then it brought you to where you are
today that's the point is I mean many
people find Islam through the other
through the Quran or through many many
many many things but what happened to me
was I became his story actually I
accepted Islam through history and that
made me a historian that made me a
Muslim a Muslim historian mashaallah so
hum do we learn nowadays I can proudly
say that Islam and history goes together
for me history brought me to Islam and
Islam probably further hamdullah so 26
years later I have realized that a lot
of myths and a lot of lies were told to
us that time I was going to a Greek
school Greek primary school
the same lies and stories that were
telling them that time they're telling
them even nowadays but the difference is
that many have woken up and many have
seen that yes not all of these things
they are telling us at school were true
and not all of these things they are
telling us even nowadays are true and
are to be believed so please be careful
that's all I have to say please be
careful what they're telling you at
school look deeper into it find out what
actually happened in history as
difficult it difficult as it might seem
in the end Allah showed me the way
alhamdulillah so I can just say that
alhamdulillah I mean the truth of
history led me to Islam to the truth of
our life and this was more important
actually that history itself you know
but that led me to the deep I
interviewed a former NFL alumni and he's
also from the Greek Perique background
okay and his name is Tim and inshallah
this show so gets to him where he comes
from the Greek background he's been
hanging around with some Muslims and
he's really liking he I gifted him a
crown and some of the other literature
Tom about the purpose of life and you
know the miracles in Islam prophecies
all of the authenticity of the Quran
list goes on because we don't just
blindly surrender in Islam is based on
tactics evidence facts proves all right
so now he's actually been given about
six seven months to live he has a I
believe it's some form of leukemia and
they thought they pretty much written
him off and now he's been exposed to
Muslims but now he's also at this
crucial point in his life what advice
you coming from a Greek background you
can connect with him but the pressure is
now the pressure he's he's gotten
outside did some programs with him he's
talking you know on behalf of all the
good experiences that he's had with
Muslims but now death is approaching and
he's in a battle like okay my Greek
background Christian or Orthodox
Christian and now this is coming to him
what advice do you have for him very
simple one
the most important thing your greek
nests whatever you feel that you are
you're Greek you will stay Greek you
will die quicker whoever you are
whatever you you will you believe is in
the end you will be Greek you are you
will die the Greek
one important thing is you're gonna
stand in front of your Creator the
Creator is not gonna ask you what your
good Greek you know how did you live
your life is a Greek but the Creator is
gonna ask you how did you worship me how
did you worship God do you believe in
God who is God what do you believe God
is actually who do you believe brought
God to you who was the messenger so
being Greek has nothing to do with
finding the death angels later who will
be waiting for you on your bedside so be
careful of that really look at that you
that your life is coming to an end a new
life is starting and it can be happy or
it can be very sad you know and being
Greek has nothing to do the end is very
important and hopefully insha'Allah look
into the Dean look into what you create
that told you to do forget if it's
called Islam or Christianity orthodoxy
or Catholicism look into who's the
creator what did the Creator tell us to
do look at the authentic sources and
find out actually what an end a good end
would be for you so that's my advice
actually look into it and forget what
people say forget everything that your
surrounding is telling you that is not
going to help you know surrounding no
Greek nursing we're leaving a crater and
you will see him each other you will
ensure Amitabh later
do you speak Greek I speak yes say
something good
how you doing the katakana how would
someone respond to that the Connie said
Nicola
color yes the Khan is color so how do we
test if you want to know how do I know
you maybe just fake okay okay let's ask
one of my key texts a delay to Islam he
talks to the lady
Revere I mean my blade economist woman
SEO so he Belgium in a poodle
as leather paramecia says Lenin
Methuselah nips eMeter Oscar bro so he
okay we did the authenticity test all
right tell us one minute pass it tell us
tell us how one more thing
tell us one of the myths that was
perpetuated in in the schools growing up
and what the reality was the Ottoman
Empire the Ottomans coming to turn to
Greece as I said the Turks as they call
them coming and raping our women taking
our children or we're making them all
Janissaries now the question that I had
was if they made all our young boys
Janissaries then how come we still have
a Greek nation how come we Greeks are
still there we still speak Greek and
we're still Greek we're Greek nation
raping all our women
well what happened to all of them they
still after that there was a Greek
nation still as it was a Serbian nation
as it was a Bosnian nation and Albanian
and so on and so on so again they
exaggerated history is sometimes is
nothing else but a bunch of lies you
know put together so we have to be
careful we have to be careful just look
at it from a neutral perspective try to
look at history from a different
perspective for a more neutral one if
you can otherwise history is a very
biased thing you know Churchill said
yeah history is written by the winners
by the victors Churchill Churchill yes
you want to really make sure its history
not as we say his history yeah you had
this tragic terrorist attack that
happened just recently by this person
who came into a house of worship people
are worshiping the one God the Creator
connecting with their creator trying to
have peace the guy comes in and
massacres was a fifty innocent human
beings women were killed you had
children also what would you because
you've also helped through this history
D radicalize people because this
national
nationalism and then some people they
try to hide behind a religion a certain
religion but you educate them through
history to give the facts to D
radicalize them to help you know stop
people like this who are out there how
does your work how would how would your
work more people being exposed to it and
Islam help to stop people like this who
have these twisted deranged crazy
psychopathic ideas to go and gun down
in it innocent human beings well a big
topic that you mentioned here now a very
big one we should not forget that people
like him you know the terrorists of New
Zealand basically there's many people
have this mindset they believe that
Islam is a problem for the West of a
certain countries that the Muslims come
here to invade us but again what I'm
trying to rectify is not only our past
history but also our very our present
basically is this all true it is really
like this that Muslims are here to
eradicate the Western culture of Western
civilization what is a Muslim actually
because believe me she had asked him or
if you ask him what does it mean Islam
he won't be able to tell you I'm sure
that he wouldn't be able to tell you
what Islamist terrorists would have no
idea he would just say terrorist but he
observes it errors basically so this
education is very important education on
the right path it's very important that
that's the most important thing and
don't lie to our children don't lie to
our youngsters don't lie to them I heard
something crazy in Greece 2012 the
documentary came out and there was a
bunch of academics Greek academics who
came together and made this documentary
an excellent documentary the first time
that I saw some records on Greek TV and
they admitted that indeed all these
decades we were lying to our children
they admitted this openly and when they
were asked why why is the system like
this in Greece why do we have to lie to
our youngsters they said listen to that
because we want our youngsters to
the country and my question is if you
need to lie to your come to your
youngsters in order for them to love you
to come that country then there's
something wrong with the country right
so it's crazy yes it's crazy so yeah
this is this is very sad state because
you see like with this hate it
perpetuates more hate and then that
leads to violence like we saw in New
Zealand what had happened and do you do
you see that this is because we don't
obviously blame Christianity and like
people will go ahead and as soon as
someone somehow anyhow connected to
Islam
now preppies yes and then they'll right
away 24/7 media coverage that's even a
known fact that you know someone who's
connected to being a Muslim or Muslim a
whatever the case five times more media
coverage it's pumped out and the fear
machine starts to push off the table
Buganda but you didn't see in this case
you know this guy making a pledge to the
Templar knights you know he was chanting
you know this Chetnik Serbian song they
admitted this was genocide and they were
on a crusade to eradicate Muslim Union
so when you see that as a historian what
underlining for what's going on behind
the scenes that many of the people
they're not aware of that do you think
they should be aware yeah history indeed
it brings you back to history it brings
you back to a twisted idea of history by
the way because this is what you just
mentioned what his idea was of history
was a twisted mindset of history and a
misunderstanding and or rather yeah
misunderstanding of history and of of
myths again as we just explained the
idea of myths and and and lies that have
become the truth to him and to everybody
was following him basically so in the
end it is very important to get a clear
education a clear understanding of what
it actually means what history means
what the truth is in history and what
are lies and we have to start
distinguishing that's the truth that's
the lie and that is that can be very
difficult for certain individuals okay
but it all goes back to your mindset how
how do you understand your surrounding
how do you understand people around you
and I mean this individual obviously has
it twisted Mantid and and unfortunately
it's not the only one there are many
more who have a twisted mindset and we
have to try to correct them try to find
out what can we do what do you think
because we we we ourselves anyone and
let's say the community of Muslims as
soon as somebody has these twisted ideas
these mindsets we as a collective
community we've become like professional
condemned errs yeah right people who do
some things that are just totally
opposite to Islam foreign to it's not
there's no sanction whatsoever in Islam
we're the first to call them out even
though we don't have a platform to be
like you know out there on a microphone
constantly with the media but now what
about these these these radicals people
who are hiding we don't believe these
people represent Christianity but now is
it a duty of the good Christians out
there so many of them to go ahead and
call out when they see some of these
zealots these radicals coming out and
they try to hide behind their religion
to go ahead and call them out because
that's that growing threat they say
far-right but when you look at who these
people are they're actually they would
be connected somehow to Christian but we
don't again we don't blame Christianity
or Christians but you have to come out
and like Muslims do to go ahead and call
these black sheep out what do you think
about what happens as soon as it's
somebody we saw didn't Larry some years
back in in Belgium some kind of deluded
person I don't what it was was a
criminal who was in prison a Moroccan
guy or with a Moroccan surname he were
not they killed some people and suddenly
it was a Muslim thing again it was a
terrorist act by a Muslim so you're
absolutely right as soon as it's
somebody with a Muslim name as somebody
who has a Muslim background it is his
land that has to be put on a cross but
here there was they didn't check into
what kind of church he went to they
didn't ask for any white leader to
apologize for what this person did this
terrorist nobody asked any specific
organization where he went to what he
did but they would had it been a Muslim
he would have been of course all over
the media she said five times more
coverage and
would have been they would have looked
into what mosque he has been to who has
radicalized this person who might this
person believe the things that he
believed so absolutely right I mean what
can I say on this one that is
unfortunately the sad state of affairs
that we're in now at the moment we have
to and I still believe we should not
just go out and condemn every time when
something is happening like that
especially as Muslims why do I have in
the UK in Greece in Germany have to
condemn somebody did something in in
Asia or in America what yeah so that's a
good point so just like Christians don't
have to come out and condemn every time
some lunatic like this does that same
thing they shouldn't hold Muslims
responsible for some some deranged
lunatic psychopath who does something
opposite to the teachings of Islam
absolutely yes a couple more points
before we come to a close now that you
have many Croatians and being almost at
the Pope we're going to be visiting
Bosnia and shell out soon
you have I hear a lot of great stories
double capture and Charlotte will enough
Serbians accepting Islam and again you
don't change your DNA or become a
Bosnian because you and came a Muslim
one has submitted their will to the
crater Croatians accepting Islam they
don't believe in trinity worshipping a
man or these things are confusing God
three and one no just worship one God
straightforward simple based on proof
and evidence now the challenge that they
have you know just like you had but you
look you're an example of courage or
you're an example of someone who
transcended that what advice do you have
for them very simple look into what the
message actually is what is the message
is it forget the name Islam Christianity
everything else just looking to your
Creator you are created that's a clear
fact you are created by somebody okay
this somebody is who this Creator is who
how do you find this creator now let's
forget all names calling name callings
and forgettin you know religion Islam
Christianity let's just look at the
Creator wouldn't the Creator want us to
write to recognize him what the great I
want us to worship him how do you
worship him now we all know if you look
at movies about Jesus how did he worship
didn't he fall down on the ground like
we do as Muslims dainty worship a large
part of God the way that we see Muslims
worshiping them then Jesus look like
Muslim like we look nowadays so I mean
at least a clear factor there is not
there's not a lot that you can say about
it it's very clear if you want to and I
tell you one thing I was actually even
fighting against it actively for a
moment there was some times that I
thought no it cannot be
you didn't want it you don't want to
submit in Islam absolutely you don't
want to accept but I looked into that
that way that okay forget Islam I said
just say forget that this is called
Islam look into the facts if God wants
you to submit to him and this is the way
that you know that others have submitted
to him that you know that Jesus has
admitted to him so hey you might call it
Islam but in the end that's the truth so
it doesn't really matter what you call
it in the end
it's one God and you worship this one
creator and the way you worship Him is
also very clear the Quran is next very
very clear the Quran is is proven that
it has never changed the Quran is out
there and it's always a state the same
there's no difference in the Quran or as
we have different Bibles we know that
yeah so I mean what more can I say kids
don't get caught up in the names look at
what really what the message is and
that's calling the human being to
worship the Creator not the creation I
always say if you can dig that you will
be able to dig the rest it will all fall
in place now tell us about this book as
a historian you have this you have
another book coming out on top of the
book that you already have and working
people there is the last two to three
years I have been busy with gathering
sources here left and right and up and
down and in any kind of languages and
they said textbook coming out and
sharing Ramadan in May this textbook is
about Islam and Europe how did Islam
enter Europe how has it become part of
Europe I call it actually and we are
looking into the three routes it means
Al Andalus so Spain Portugal Italy and
so on the Ottoman Empire and the Tatars
so these are the three routes as well as
we're looking into the Vikings there has
been called there was it's proven that
there was connections between the
Vikings and the Muslims especially in
al-andalus they have been Viking so
accepted Islam
and the last issues the English version
will focus on the British Isles as well
you would not say that Britain and the
British arts in general had have a
history of Islam law all along before in
the nineteen sixties and seventies were
many Pakistani guest workers came over
here so it is not necessarily something
new for the British out for example not
at all so yeah this is the one textbook
with regards to the English textbook the
German textbook focuses also on the
german-speaking country so Germany
Austria Switzerland as amazing history's
absolutely amazing and this book is
called the history of Islam in Europe
yeah it's a textbook you will find it
from Ramallah on each other from me
whoever wants can contact me how the how
can I contact you info add staff carries
that come so my name info add staff
character come that's it and you got so
much so many gems here from this program
so many things that you can benefit from
we cleared a lot of these misconceptions
miss notions and go ahead and leave some
of the takeaways that you are able to
take away from this episode here
someone's struggling also from NASA
Missa tee a lot of false propaganda is
perpetuated against Muslims in Islam we
said put the nametags really see what
Islam means look at the meaning and the
message behind it I know that the truth
will always be resisted every time
there's the true but it's going to be
fought so go ahead and if you like what
we had to say continue to tune in read
the book and there was one interesting
gentleman a scholar who was actually
from from Britain in the book that you
talk about what was his name that
accepted Islam yeah Abdul like William
William he accepted Islam in the
nineteenth century he's a well known
figure he's a well known figure in the
bridge say his name again
Abdul like William William yeah he
became the Sheikh al-islam of the
British Isles by the Ottoman Empire and
he was living in Victorian England and
he stablished the first mosque ever in
this country in Britain Britain and he
was a white solicitor you know
white guy who accepted Islam so
not Pakistan you know from outside not
African and through him actually more
than 100 people except that his love
group if not even more I mean that's
amazing it's an amazing life we covered
a lot so this is another gem that's it
that's in the book if you like the idea
of worshipping only one God to know your
purpose why you're here where you're
going when you die and is based on
evidence and proof read the Quran
connect with us continue to tune into
the Deen show we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you so now I'm
a goon